another article from the daily wires is
a nine-year-old girl who was one of the
three um
school children gunned down by the
national shooter inside a Christian
School was desperately trying to stop
the massacre by pulling on a fire alarm
when she was murdered
and there as I mentioned yesterday there
have been many stories and reports of
heroism inside the school
um
and uh including one of the teachers
that was that was killed was apparently
running towards the shooter trying to
protect her children
um and in this case it was Evelyn who
was running to pull the fire alarm to
protect her her classmates in her school
incredible bravery
um
also infuriating because that little
girl should not have been in a situation
where she was called on to be heroic
um which is why we need armed security
in all the schools
it's uh it's incredible to hear about
the stories of teachers that are rushing
at you to unarmed teachers rushing at
Shooters small children that are acting
to try to to try to protect their
classmates
um these are heroic
Acts
but they shouldn't be in a position
where they have to do that okay the
teacher shouldn't be in a position who
that are who are unarmed shouldn't be in
a position having to throw themselves at
armed assailants
which is why again there needs to be
there need to be guns in the school guns
that are carried by the good guys
armed security armed teachers we need
all of that
and that's you know if that's not just
apparent by now to everyone then then I
I don't know at what point does it
become clear
of course on the left they go the other
direction here's Randy Weingarten
calling for the repeal of the Second
Amendment in response to this
an epidemic that our great nation must
solve
and how many lives
will be shattered
before we have the courage to do what
Scotland did with Australia did what New
Zealand did what other great democracies
do
we must solve this epidemic
and that's up to us
yeah that's uh that is directly calling
for the appeal the Second Amendment and
uh and a kind of unilateral disarmament
and it's not going to happen
um
and you think especially now
see they they the way it works in their
Twisted heads is after an event like
this they think this is the perfect time
to make this argument people are going
to be even more receptive to the
propaganda because they're afraid of
quote-unquote gun violence and so people
are going to be even more willing to uh
lay down their arms and get rid of their
guns but of course for rational normal
people it's exactly the opposite okay we
are not
because we're Americans and we have
rights and the Second Amendment does
exist and it's not going to be repealed
um
we're not receptive to the idea of
disarming in general
but we are the least receptive of all
right after an event like this
because this only highlights yet again
why we need to be armed
it's a it's just a it's a very simple
equation
evil exists in the world evil people
exist in the world
and if we ever encounter them we we
don't want them to have the upper hand
that's it that's all
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block you can become a member today and
use code wall should check out for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]